it's fire season in thailand
hundreds of patches of farmland and
forest
are a blaze in the north
and this helicopter team is charged with
locating the hot spots
fires belching toxic fumes into the
atmosphere
poisoning thailand's air by come by
contributing to an estimated 32 000
premature deaths in 2019.
you can really smell the smoke now and
they've been fighting this fire for two
days and this is a really
dangerous moment because all of these
ridge lines you can
see they're watching the smoke and their
concern is if the fire gets to the top
of the mountain range here
it will actually be able to jump over
then spread very quickly down the other
[Music]
side
hour after hour they empty bucket after
bucket of water
thousands of liters needed to douse the
blazes
started here by humans it's very bad
we have we not had uh
the water for waterfall for wi-fi
[Music]
and this is what they're facing on the
ground
[Music]
around a thousand fire fronts like this
have been burning across
northern thailand everything's dry
absolutely dry so fires can start very
easily
some of them are natural some of them
are started by
local farmers or whatever
david root is leading volunteers helping
to put out the flames
it's too remote for fire engines all the
equipment
has to be carried in with water we put
out
the edge of the fire
and with the leaf blowers we make a fire
break
farmers also burn crops adding to the
haze
on the worst days drifting smoke made
chiang mai the most polluted city in the
world
how have you seen the fire situation
change over the years you've lived here
as the years have progressed it's just
getting worse and worse um
so that now the last few years that
north of thailand just swayed in smoke
for
like eight weeks a year which causes a
lot of health problems
in the first three months of this year
200 000
people in eight provinces in northern
thailand
have been made ill by tiny pm 2.5
air pollution particles three-year-old
poor joy
has a lung infection it happened
authorities say they've reduced hot
spots this year
and monitoring pollution and are trying
better to control
crop burning but the annual fires here
with their toxic haze are damaging tens
of
thousands of lives siobhan robbins
sky news thailand